es gibt tatsächlich ein mittel gegen
alzheimer man muss es nur vorzeitig
anwenden dann kann es sogar alzheimer
verhindern
rund 15 prozent der menschen über 80
jahren wird ansonsten nämlich an
alzheimer erkrankt es kann also jeden
von uns treffen und es gibt immer noch
keine medizin dagegen
doch die forschung gibt nicht auf warum
ich bin im rahmen der kampagne forschung
ist die beste medizin
bei dem pharmaunternehmen boehringer
ingelheim und erfahren mehr über die
forschung zu dieser demenz-erkrankung
vfa
das ist übrigens der verband der
forscher in pharmaunternehmen klicks um
science-fiction das täglich spannende
science - abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocken nur dann verpasst
er nichts los geht's alzheimer ist eine
brutale krankheit so langsam blendet man
sich bei vollem bewusstsein aus dem
eigenen leben aus man bekommt mit wie
man alles vergisst und am schluss sich
selbst das ist schon ziemlich
beängstigend und die pharmaforschung
scheint wirklich in diesem fall auf der
stelle zu treten und das seit 100 jahren
quasi die forschung fischt im trüben
so würde ich nicht nennen aber das große
bild braucht eine gewisse zeit um die
einzelnen puzzleteile zusammen zu führen
dennoch scheinen unternehmen wie
boehringer nicht aufzugeben warum es
gibt nämlich trotzdem erfolge und
zumindest was das wissen angeht dr
cornelia donnerstag alzheimer forscherin
bei boehringer ingelheim
wir haben viel gelernt darüber was
alzheimer ausmacht wir haben viel
verstanden über was im gehirn falsch
läuft oder viel läuft wir haben noch
nicht verstanden wie die einzelnen
elemente miteinander führt miteinander
verknüpft sind und wir haben gelernt
dass die alzheimer erkrankung einer
erkrankung ist die aussicht nicht in dem
moment wo der patient die symptome merkt
dass er sachen vergisst und sich nichts
mehr merken kann sondern zu dem
zeitpunkt hat er schon zehn jahre lang
mindestens alzheimer sprich und das ist
wirklich tragisch wenn die krankheit
ausbricht ist es zu spät der neben den
patienten wenn er schon
fortgeschrittenen stadium alzheimer ist
und versuchen ihn dann zu behandeln weil
wir es mit dem jetzigen methoden vorher
nicht detektieren können so ein bisschen
ähnlich niemand würde
in fahrt mit einem cholesterinsenker
behandeln und das ist das was wir
versucht haben und wo wir wie sie
richtig sagen als gesamte
pharmaforschung verloren haben und
nichts gewonnen haben
das habe ich persönlich noch nie von
einer forscherin oder einem forscher
gehört praktisch ist die forschung in
100 jahren gescheitert und weiß einfach
zu wenig über diese krankheit wir packen
unser herzblut rein und wir glauben
daran dass das was wir machen richtig
ist sonst würden wir es nicht machen
in dem moment wo wir dann sehen dass was
wir an das was wir wirklich geglaubt
haben funktioniert in der klinik lich
ist das frustriert ja aber der patient
bleibt da und er hat absolut nichts
davon wenn ich nicht ins bett lege
abenteurer und am nächsten tag sagt ich
mache jetzt was anderes und keine ahnung
bauer autors das hilft ja nicht also was
wir machen ist das was wir gelernt haben
ihn zu integrieren in neue projekte in
neue forschungsstrategien in der
hoffnung diesmal soll es besser
ja ich bin kein arzt ich kann keine
smartphones und ähnliches erfinden oder
design aber ich glaube ich habe die
fähigkeiten und die chance letztendlich
dazu beizutragen dass wir ein medikament
entwickeln können gegen eine der großen
krankheiten als geißel der menschheit
ein absolut beeindruckende statement
doch es gibt einen trost denn die
hirnforschung hat tatsächlich etwas
herausgefunden und zwar wie man eine
alzheimer erkrankung vorbeugen kann
und das ist wirklich ein konkretes
ergebnis der forschung und das heißt ab
50 weiter aktiv bleiben und zwar mit dem
körper und dem gehirn sich fordern und
kein couch potato werden dann so die
forschung sinkt das risiko erheblich
jegliche hirn krankheiten zu bekommen
wow das ist ja schon mal ein erster
ansatz ja ich finde es mal wirklich
spannend erfahren zu haben wie forschung
nicht weiterkommt in einem anderen video
da geht es darum wie alzheimer früher
erkannt werden kann
dazu geht es hier also anklicken
anschauen und das ist nix und science
fiction abonnieren wer das noch nicht
getan habe bis dann bleibt dran